[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing Lord
Voldemort's loyal followers the Death
Eaters discussing how powerful they
truly are in fact we'll be ranking the
top five most powerful now we know that
when Voldemort was just a boy at school
he was in Slytherin house and it was
here that he formed a gang a fellow star
in students
Dumbledore described riddles gang as a
mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking glory and the
thuggish seeking a leader who could show
the more refined cruelty it was these
same students that are considered to be
the forerunners to what would become the
Death Eaters that we see later on in the
books and films Death Eaters are
pureblood radical supremacists they cast
unforgivable curses without remorse and
torture muggles half-bloods and blood
traitors alike there are quite a few
Death Eaters that we know by name but
we'll just be looking at the five most
powerful number five Fenrir Greyback
though Grayback is not an official full
status Death Eater he was still
considered to be a low-level Death Eater
the main reasons for him never becoming
a full-fledged Death Eater with it a he
was a werewolf and B he sort of had his
own agenda Grayback was a werewolf known
for his animalistic brutality and
tendency to target those who were
helpless particularly children Remus
Lupin is like Han thorpey was the result
of being bitten by gray back as a child
gray back is about as scary as they come
and has also shown cannibalistic
tendencies his life goal was to infect
as many with I can through P as possible
and bring power back to werewolves among
other things grey back was an impressive
duelist took Ron and Neville's combined
efforts to defeat him and nonverbal
magic expert grey back also possessed
superhuman strength which can't hurt
it's worth mentioning the gray back
never had the dark mark placed upon his
arm the signature mark of the Death
Eaters number 4
Antonin doll of Antonin doll Hoth was
dark pure blood wizard and one of Lord
Voldemort's most loyal followers he was
involved in both the first and second
Wizarding Wars
and was responsible for torturing
countless muggles and non supporters of
the Dark Lord
Dolokhov was personally responsible for
defeating the powerful or a mad I Moody
as well as Remus Lupin when dueling the
powerful Sirius Black
dollar Hoth held his own dollar Hobbes
perhaps most humiliating moment was when
he was put face to face with Ron
Hermione and Harry Hermione was able to
take control of the situation and $4
half in a full-body ban curse however
the famous trio have been able to
accomplish some amazing things together
so I'm really not too surprised
Dolokhov was highly skilled at
Transfiguration the dark arts Julie
nonverbal magic charms and even spell
creation notably creating the famous
purple jet that we know to come out at
the end of his wand number three
Barty Crouch jr. Barty Crouch jr.
was a British pureblood wizard in the
son of Ministry of Magic official party
miss Crouch senior Crouch jr. has a rich
history with the Death Eaters and joined
them in his teenage years among other
notable accomplishments Crouch was the
first wizard ever to escape from Azkaban
and it's 300 year history
Barty famously kidnaps and imprisons the
powerful mad-eye moody then teaches a
Hogwarts School for an entire year in
his stead what's so impressive about
this is that he was completely
undetected even by the powerful
Dumbledore he torched defense against
the dark arts and was actually a pretty
good professor teaching his class all
about the unforgivable curses in his
earlier years
Barty Crouch jr. was responsible for
torturing nevels parents and powerful
auras Frank and Alice Longbottom he was
instrumental in Voldemort resurgence and
was eventually reduced to nothing after
being kissed by a demented a fate
arguably worse than death Crouch was
powerful in every area of magic and was
known to be skilled at dueling potions
charms Transfiguration aqua mint see
nonverbal magic and more in my opinion
Crouch may be one of the most underrated
Wizards in all of history number two
Bellatrix Lestrange you were probably
wondering when Bellatrix would show up
in this list
Bellatrix Lestrange was one of if not
Voldemort most loyal follower she was a
frightening pureblood witch that came
from the strange family
and a long line of powerful witches and
wizards with a twisted agenda Bellatrix
was personally responsible for murdering
Sirius Black and was an extremely
talented witch she was one of the most
powerful people in the Wizarding World
period and basically only came after
Dumbledore Voldemort and the number one
spot on this list which I'll tell you
about in a minute Bellatrix was a known
proponent of Cruciatus curse and had
considerable knowledge in the realm of
the dark arts she was also an expert
duelists charms expert powerful
Aquaman's and tenacious warrior she was
one of the most twisted Death Eaters and
derived a considerable pleasure from
torturing people finding the suffering
of others to be amusing she was
eventually defeated by Molly Weasley
which i think was really just the result
of her not taking Molly seriously her
confidence was overinflated and she
didn't focus when the two were dueling
laughing hysterically throughout Molly
in a full motherly protective mode
bested Bellatrix and she was never to be
seen again
number one Severus Snape now we know
Severus Snape as Lily's suitor the
potions professor the Defense Against
the Dark Arts professor and later
headmaster of Hogwarts
despite Snape ultimately showing huge
one of the good guys
he did have a history with the Death
Eaters and was crooked for a time Snape
after all was the one responsible for
telling Voldemort about the prophecy
professor Trelawney had predicted
Snape is widely considered to be one of
the most gifted wizards in the entire
Harry Potter series his skills are
really only outmatched by Voldemort and
Dumbledore who were in a bit of a class
of their own but Snape is extremely
powerful nonetheless during his time at
Hogwarts Snape assumed the identity the
half-blood Prince and scribbled all
sorts of spell creations into his copy
of advanced potion making among these
spells was the powerful and vicious
Sectumsempra Snape can also fly and is
one of only two known Wizards who are
capable of doing this
the other being Voldemort when Snape
jewels McGonagall is clearly holding
back but is still matching an extremely
powerful witch this is similar to the
scene in the ministry atrium where
Dumbledore was holding back against
Voldemort but to a more significant
degree Snape is also cited as saying
that
Voldemort is the most accomplished
Lederman's the world has ever seen which
would mean that him being able to keep
falling Mort out of his mind would in a
way make him one of the best Oklahomans
there's truly no telling what Snape
would have been able to accomplish if he
had lived a longer life and I think that
he truly deserves the number one spot in
this list honorable mentions include
Corbin Yaxley Peter Pettigrew and Lucius
Malfoy I think that you could even make
an argument for their placement on this
list and that's it for this video I hope
you enjoyed it
what do you think of these rankings what
would you change let me know down in the
comments section below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
you